quel est votre premier souvenir de
spectateur mes parents sur scène mais
c'est flou votre première émotion sur
grand écran les dents de la mer j'avais
2 ans et demi votre dernier coup de cœur
en
salle du tac au tac kfou en a deux
Alexandre une salle de cinéma préféré
oui celle qui est à côté de chez moi le
paté bcour à Lyon avez-vous un film
culte les dents de la mer excusez-moi
parce que justement c'est celui que j'ai
vu à 2 ans et demi un film que vous avez
honte d'aimer non j'ai pas de film dont
que j'ai honte d'aimer un classique qui
ne vous a jamais touché Orange Mécanique
le film qui vous a traumatisé durant
votre enfance non mon père m'a fait voir
les dents de la mre à 2 ans et demi j'ai
pas pu être traumatisé de rien du tout
désolé le film qui vous fait
systématiquement hurl de rire les vieux
de la vieille avez-vous une réplique de
cinéma que vous aimez utiliser dans la
vie il nous faudra un plus gros bateau
dans les dents de la mer quelle est
votre bande originale de film préféré la
attaque des clones quelle est l'actrice
qui vous touche le
plus Isabelle adjan l'acteur qui vous
touche le
plus Philip c'est mon hman quelle est
votre principale qualité sur un plateau
le calme votre principal défaut le calme
avec qui aimeriezvous tourner oublé le
cinéaste à qui vous êtes prêt à tout
pardonner Lucas auteur compositeur
scénariste réalisateur comédien quel est
votre principal plaisir professionnel la
composition musicale quel autre métier
auez-vous plus ou aimé faire
astrophysicien avez-vous un rêve
[Musique]
ultime vivre assez vieux pour le premier
voyage pour aller dans l'espace
avez-vous un objet
fétiche j'ai une chaise avec mon nom
derrière qui m'a été offerte par mon
camarade Jean-Christophe Ambert avec qui
je fais à peu près tout ce que je
fabrique et que peut-on vous souhaiter
aujourd'hui de vivre assez vieux pour
aller un jour dans
[Applaudissements]
l'espace